S
WOULD BE COMPARING APPLES TO
APPLES.
A LOOK AT THE CHART COMPARED BY
THE RNC.
DURING THE LATEST JANUARY 6TH
HEARING, FAR MORE AMERICANS WERE
GOOGLING GAS PRICES THEN WERE
SEARCHING THE WEB FOR
JANUARY 6TH.
HERE WITH MORE, MINORITY LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY.
FIRST OF ALL, ALL RIGHT, THE
INFORMATION COMES ABOUT YOU AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THINGS YOU
HAVE SAID REGARDING THIS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT YOU
GUYS HAD A SPLIT.
ALL OF A SUDDEN YOU SHOW UP IN A
MEETING AND APPARENTLY YOU GUYS
ARE ON THE SAME PAGE AGAIN.
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> WE HAVE OUR CONVERSATIONS ALL
THE TIME.
IT'S VERY INTERESTING BUT THERE
IS NO SPLIT BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND DIED.
WE ARE FOCUSED ON MAKING SURE
THE COUNTRY COMES BACK IN THE
POLICY THAT MAKES US STRONG.
AMERICA FIRST WITH LOW GAS
PRICES, A SECURE BORDER, SAFE
STREETS, WE'VE GOT A FUTURE
WHERE KIDS CAN GROW UP IN.
YOU SHOWED THE GRAPH, THEY HAD
THIS JANUARY 6TH MEETING HEARSAY
OVERWHELMINGLY PEOPLE WERE
GOOGLING ABOUT GAS PRICES.
IT SHOWN US THAT NOW FAMILIES
ARE SPENDING 311 MORE DOLLARS
PER MONTH.
THAT'S PAYING FOR A NEW CAR
WITHOUT GETTING A CAR.
64% OF AMERICANS AREN'T DRIVING
TO THE GROCERY STORE LESS
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO GET
THERE.
>> Sean: WHAT WILL BE
DIFFERENT IN NOVEMBER NEXT
JANUARY WHEN THE NEW CONGRESS IS
IN PLACE?
IT'S A REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN
THE HOUSE AND LET'S SAY THE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY IN THE
SENATE.
IT WILL WOULD BE DIFFERENT?
>> WE TAKE OVER THE HOUSE AND
WILL MAKE A COMMITMENT TO
AMERICA.
WE WILL LAY OUT EXACTLY WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO DO.
MAKE AMERICA ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
IT PUT MORE MONEY INTO THE
POCKET AND SECURE THE BORDER.
THE OTHER THING WILL DO IS MAKE
SURE THE STREETS ARE SAFE.
WE ARE GOING TO GO INTO THE
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE THEM --
ONLY IF THE D.A.'S UPHOLD EVERY
SINGLE LAW.
WE WILL PROVIDE A PARENT'S BILL
OF RIGHT THAT YOU HAVE THE RIGHT
TO SAY WHERE YOU WANT YOUR KIDS
TO GO TO SCHOOL.
THAT'S THE START OF WHAT WILL
DO.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT, YOU'VE
BEEN TRYING TO PRESSURE, RIGHTLY
SO, AND REPUBLICANS HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET NANCY PELOSI TO
GET ON THE DOCKET, SECURITY FOR
THE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES.
I CANNOT BELIEVE THAT PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER AND THE DEMOCRATS
APPROVED PROTESTING IN FRONT OF
JUSTICES HOMES.
AMY CONEY BARRETT'S KIDS SCHOOL
BEING DOCKED, THE LOCATION.
HER CHURCH IS BEING DOXED.
THEY GAVE A TIMELINE OF WHEN SHE
GOES TO CHURCH.
THIS IS MORE THAN HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION.
IT TO ME, IT'S A CLEAR AND
PRESENT DANGER FOR EVERY
JUSTICE.
YOU SAW WHAT HAPPENED WITH
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
WHY WILL NANCY PELOSI NOT
PROVIDE THE SECURITY THAT THEY
DESERVE?
>> THIS BILL PASSED THE SENATE
100-0.
NANCY PELOSI HAS HELD THE BILL
FOR ONE MONTH.
I'VE GONE TO THE FLOOR THREE
TIMES TO ASK FOR UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO BRING THE BILL UP TO
SEND IT TO THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
WE SAW AN INDIVIDUAL TRAVEL FROM
CALIFORNIA, THE ONLY REASON HE
WAS PICKED UP AND STOPPED IT WAS
BECAUSE HE SAW SECURITY AT THE
HOUSE OF JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
HAD JUSTICE KAVANAUGH NOT BEEN
THERE, THE SECURITY WOULDN'T BE
THERE.
HIS FAMILY, HIS SPOUSE WOULD NOT
BE, SAFE.
IF YOU HAVE A WHITE HOUSE THAT
SAID YES, THEY SHOULD BE ENGAGED
AND GOING TO THE HOUSES AND
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION.
YOU'VE GOT CHUCK SCHUMER GOING
TO THE SUPREME COURT SAYING
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY THE PRICE,
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
IF THIS IS WHAT HE SAID.
>> Sean: IF I DO THAT, I'D BE
ACCUSED OF INSURRECTION.
IT'S UNREAL.
SPEAK ABOUT NANCY PELOSI HOLDS
THIS.
IF THE OTHER THING
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND, WHAT THE DEMOCRATS
WANT TO DO IS CHANGE THE BILL.
NOT TO MAKE IT BETTER, BUT TO
SEND IT BACK TO THE HOUSE AND
DELAY IT.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN.
YOU'VE GOT A SUPREME COURT --
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT,
THEY'LL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THOSE PEOPLE GETTING APPROVAL
AND ENCOURAGING.
DOXXING, PROTESTING, HARASSMEN